Let me show you what happens when we run that. So I wrote to the file
corpus.pkl. If we did a really long crawl, we'd want to make sure that file's
protected, so we don't write it over again. And then if we ran the crawler the
second time, now we get an error, permission is denied and we catch that
exception and see the message. Let's take a little peek at what's actually in
that file, and you can see that it's not impossible to make sense of. We don't
really care what's in it as long as pickle load and does what pickle dub does,
what's in there could be anything, but we can see that it's stored the webcorpus
object, and we can see some of the contents we expect in there and lots of other
stuff.